de Gulliver crack
le plus grand problème c'est avec
l'électricité qui a les répercussions
pour de nombreux secteurs notamment le
transport mais les chemins de fer
ukrainien disent avec avec regret qu'il
y a un certain nombre de trains qui ont
du retard mais le nombre de trains avec
un retard de plus d'une heure et de
seulement 3 si je me souviens bien donc
ils sont relativement fiers de leur
performance en faisant circuler les
trains malgré les problèmes
d'électricité il y a des coupures de
courant pour de nombreuses foyers dont
la région où je me trouve Vinicia
apparemment plus de 200 communes sont
actuellement sans électricité une
centrale électrique dans cette région a
été touchée hier matin il y a eu
plusieurs centrales électriques et
autres installations du système de
distribution d'électricité qui ont été
touchés ces derniers jours cela a obligé
l'Ukraine aussi à cesser ses
exportations d'électricité et si on a la
région de Kiev et je pense pas
uniquement la région de Kev il y a
maintenant un système de
distribution d'électricité par horaires
il y aura quelques heures où il y aura
pas et puis ça va être reproché pendant
quelques heures les autorités régionales
pour la région de kievres ont publié
l'emploi du temps quand est-ce qu'il y
aura de l'électricité et sinon sur tout
le pays les citoyens sont appelés à
utiliser le moins d'électricité possible
sur